when I was a startup developer I would
write nightly batch jobs those jobs were
long and linear as they ran on one
single server but now we have Cloud run
jobs which can spin up many containerist
workers for us in the cloud that means
our batch jobs can finish sooner and if
one worker crashes most work still gets
done let's say I want to send one email
per record in a database table with
Cloud run jobs I can create a new job
with many workers let's pick 10 when my
code runs it gets these two environment
variables my code can use them to
calculate which records this particular
worker should send an email for
when all the records assigned to this
worker have been processed I simply exit
this approach works whenever you need to
process multiple independent items like
database records or files now put your
batch jobs in Cloud run jobs that will
finish sooner and there will be more
robust